[Music]
under the cover of darkness
a midnight display of massive military
muscle
and leading the pyongyang parade a huge
new weapon which analysts say could be
the world's largest
intercontinental ballistic missile
crowds mobilized to mark and celebrate
the moment
and presiding over it all kim jong-un
high up and looking down defying
coronavirus
which he says hasn't hit north korea
let me take this opportunity to console
the people all over the world
who battled the disease caused by a
malicious virus
i sincerely hope people can keep their
health happiness and smiles
above all i feel very grateful for all
our people being healthy and sound
taking his place unmasked flanked by
followers even embracing children
he claims his country is covered free
but few outside believe him and earlier
in the day at events commemorating the
75th anniversary
of the workers party state-run tv
showed several people wearing face
coverings
these events aren't uncommon but remain
an extraordinary site
you stepping in time drilled to perfect
precision
even the tears seem highly rehearsed
but behind the spectacle the message
the most totalitarian of states in
control
and command of its power and people
armed
and isolated from the world but united
within
laura bundock sky news